it's uh it's always fun to talk to you
because you always have such interesting
things going on the characters you play
are interesting there's always so many
layers to everything that it's always a
good conversation
thank you for saying so that's uh that
makes me feel uh that makes me feel uh
good about myself
well how how long had you been thinking
about
this music these songs this album before
finally deciding to actually take this
journey and see it through
um i think the answer to that is
somewhere between
two years and 20 20 22 years um i think
i think uh
22 years ago i
i sort of had my first foray into into
music and music recording and i signed
to um
simon fuller who was the manager who
came up the spice girls and everything
we were doing a sort of jazz big band
project together um which never kind of
came to fruition and i did a few um sort
of pop bam projects and
um
did some recording with some other
producers but it never it just never
really um
got any sort of wind under its wings and
and i think i got quite quickly
disillusioned with it
um
[Music]
and meanwhile the sort of acting side of
things was was sort of brewing and
and and sort of
taking my
you know peaking my curiosity and i got
excited about sort of storytelling and
stuff but i think you can see through
the through the course of my uh through
the course of my career you can see that
i was sort of navigating back whenever i
could to um
to projects that had something to do
with music uh
you know but it was always kind of
impersonations um of people and always
doing impressions even at school i would
do these sinatra tribute concerts and
stevie wonder soul nights and all of
these things that weren't really me but
just things that i loved and i think it
just
took this amount of time to sort of find
the confidence that you know my own
songs can stand up in the sort of uh
in the canon of all music ever released
and and and that i knew what i wanted it
to sound like and um
i think sometimes it takes some of us a
bit longer than others to get to that to
that to that place especially when i'm
so used to people sort of seeing me in
in a certain light so uh but but i think
honestly it just got to a point where i
was talking to
80 year old version of myself thinking
if i don't do this now i'll forever
regret
not having done it and that should far
outweigh any other argument there is for
not doing it
yeah i mean it's
easy to find yourself put into a box in
hollywood when you're good at a
particular kind of character or folks
see you a particular way
they want to keep casting you as that
because it's you know it's
they know it
has some success and it's sort of up to
the actor or the filmmaker to get people
to see them in some different way or
convince them that they can do something
they haven't seen them do before so
how do you deal with that as an actor
and at the same time does that
just feeling like people see you as an
actor then get in your head when you're
trying to work on music
i mean i think i think there's probably
always that slight initial judgment from
people of you know they they sort of
want to own that little piece of you and
and um
you know they they kind of
see you in a certain way they see you as
a certain character that they that they
love from a story or or whatever it
might be
but but um
for me i love it when people sort of try
to just try new things and and try a
different way and it's still you know to
be honest i think it's it's they're sort
of um
not totally just jointed efforts like
this it's still just a different way of
storytelling but i think having spent 20
years being edited and directed and
written for i think it's um it was just
became important for me to do something
completely from me completely sort of
raw um
and sort of authentically me
um
and i
i have no regrets about it because it's
actually made it kind of easier to
i feel like it's helped people
understand me more readily already or
something i don't know but it it's uh
it's it's definitely um
you know sort of proven to myself what
it is that i sound like and what it is
that i
have to say for myself
one of the biggest differences for you
with music when it comes to
creative and artistic fulfillment is it
as simple as when you're acting you're
playing a character and when you're
doing music that's coming from you
personally or is it not that clearly
defined
well i think i'm always trying to find
ways to sort of syringe in and and
um
find foundation in the characters that i
play with pieces of myself um but this
is a sort of a more just a just a purer
more raw uh
uh way of just sort of being expressing
myself um
and um
[Music]
plus i think i think music is just so
evocative you know when you're when
you're when you're acting you have you
know you're the way you move your body
the way you and the way you and your
facility with your voice and how you
make that sound and
you know
your kind of um
interpretation of the
of the of the lines of the of the words
um i don't need to interpret these words
because i came because i write them and
and i and i know what they felt like
i know what it felt like to to to to
mean to feel them and mean them and and
then write them down and then find music
and chords that kind of go along with it
so i think it just you know i've always
found music the the the quickest
uh emotional access
in terms of of storytelling i know how
other people's music makes me feel um in
an instant and uh and i think i was just
excited to to
to kind of share what that that it feels
like for me and and and just so curious
as to what people's reactions would be
like i'm so curious to come friday like
what people's favorite songs are what
what they connect with why what it is in
their own life that that what line of
what song makes them feel something
about their own situation rather than
uh you know just to see you know when we
talk about music we talk about sharing
it and that's what i want to do with it
i don't want to just like put it out
into the world or you know force it down
people's throats or or um
uh kind of sell it i wanna i wanna share
it
if in case the posters behind me weren't
any indication as to how much other
music with depeche mode and the cure and
tom waits and i have various posters on
my wall
i've always loved music it's always been
a part of my life but for me it was
pearl jam where i can like judge how i
was how my life was before
i found their music and how it was after
i found their music
was there a
musician or a band or somebody who did
that for you who made you fall in love
in a way that like just made you totally
re-evaluate how you looked at and heard
and and thought of music
uh i think there's a few but the
the ones that are jumping to mind now
are the band queen um you know i think
my dad listened to a lot of uh a lot of
like the great rock bands when i was
growing up as the music was always
blurry in the house there's always
something about
the rawness of freddie mercury's voice
and
and and and just the like
idiosyncrasy of
of of the songs and and
you know that i just just how how well
the the sort of the lyrics and the
and the music always seemed to be it
always seemed impossible that they ever
existed one without the other
um
so there's something and maybe maybe
it's
maybe a lot of that is nostalgia for me
and remembering i felt when i heard that
stuff for the first time i know we all
have bands like that um
and then um i remember
you know loving kind of like 70s and
motown and soul and all that stuff and
then one of my music teachers introduced
me to uh donnie hathaway in my early
teens and um
you know his voice has always been one
that is just able to cut right
through to the heart like no matter what
he's singing about um
and uh that sort of like purity and
rawness i was talking about so i think i
think those uh
not that my music particularly even
though i would love it to sound like
somewhere in between the two of them it
doesn't really does it doesn't really
sound either but they're definitely like
huge influences and um
but they were definitely like musical
awakenings those two those those two
yeah i've always loved music where you
can tell that the person and by the way
there are hundreds of others but those
are just the first two that jumped into
my head yeah no i've always loved music
where you can tell that the person
delivering it is really sort of feeling
whatever they're conveying that's why i
love
storytellers that's why you know pearl
jam always painted a picture same with
someone like tom waits he could make
even though he didn't have the best
voice he could make me cry from the
story he told
and i think that's really sort of part
of the the connection that i have to it
is is sort of that
that journey they take you on
yeah and i and i
i i love that too but i also have always
been drawn to like vocalists like even
when i was really young it was it was it
was utter james whitney houston and
michael mcdonald and freddie mercury and
and stevie wonder and those people who
just use their voices as soon as you
heard them like i know what this is so
musical so it's just extraordinary
sounds that no one else was making like
that you can immediately tell who they
are and i don't again don't necessarily
think i have any of that about me but it
is definitely what i respond to when i
listen to music
songwriting always seems like a very
elusive thing to me it's hard to you
know kind of explain how somebody comes
up with those words and that music and
it just somehow works together
and i also just it feels like it's kind
of
hard to describe how you put a
collection of songs together like how
when you were putting this collection of
songs together how did you
know that they felt right how did you
know when you were done and you should
walk away from it like how do you
how do you ever say okay i'm finished
it's a good question so well the the
the first part of it was was sort of
always phrases little phrases that that
chimed with me that then became a sort
of a bit of a
loving crossword puzzle of that i would
really enjoy the process of just like
having things fit and
looking at the the structure of
obviously how most songs are presented
and and seeing how closely i need it to
fit to that and
um
does it convey the different
perspectives of what i want to talk
about
and then finding music much more
painstaking for me because i just sit at
this uh
this piano and and move my thing because
i don't know anything about music really
in terms of keys or chords or structures
and so i just plonk away until something
sounds like the feeling that i had when
i was writing the
the the words or feeling the thing that
they then wrote the words about
um
so it definitely ends up being quite um
organic and truthful but not not
necessarily quick um
and
and then and then i think just
thematically they just felt like i've
always loved albums which feel like they
go together and this felt like a
collection of of songs that all were
about hope and all were about um empathy
and trying to see things for more than
one one side and and they were all about
sort of living in a little bit in the
gray areas you know some of the songs
are
are sort of uh
positive and and
and and and and have a vibe to them but
then they have a sort of like
melancholy undertone and some of them
are uh are very sort of more soulful and
sensitive and and and
uh
i have that feeling of pathos to them
but then there's a hopeful
undercurrent so
um
you know just more like you very sweetly
said at the beginning like just more
than one thing at a time i often say
that about acting with with a line you
know
if you're asking someone a question in a
scene
when you ask someone a question in real
life you usually are hopeful for one
answer other than another or fearing a
certain kind of answer or
you know an important question i mean
and um there's always more than one
thing at a time that's going on in your
so so i think it's that stuff is
important to to share with each other
that that things are not always black
and white
does making music videos feel like a
marriage of the two sides of you between
the acting and the music does it sort of
feel like this intersection of where
those two things meet
i yes absolutely that's exactly why i
wanted to do it and so exactly why i did
more than one music video even though it
was more sort of costly and and uh you
know i had to pull more favors and and
and uh
kind of so much more kind of uh blood
sweat and tears into into getting it
done but but but
i did want to involve people i'd work
with before i wanted to give people
opportunity to pitch ideas and and then
and then in the case of the 11 11 video
i wanted i just had a very specific
story in my head that
that um
lee krieger who's the director on shadow
and bone
pilot helped me uh you know kind of make
a reality um
but yes it was it was very much kind of
instead of just coming from left field
and being like i'm an actor but now i'm
doing music too it was more like this is
all storytelling and and this is a way
to kind of
link the two together it's the tunnel
between the between the two and help
people kind of
like i say a lot of this is wanting to
feel understood and and wanting to feel
like connected to people feel like they
can see it too and i think if i
you know music is one thing and then a
visual is another and some people are
more visual than they are oral and and
uh
you know so they can see
at least one of the threads of
storytelling that's going through your
head when you're feeling this music i
think that's that's uh that's
interesting that's interesting yeah i
mean there are music videos that have
definitely also made impressions on me i
mean the video for the music video for
losing my religion i think will always
be like my favorite
music video oh it's incredible something
so beautiful about it
well i definitely didn't want to just do
something that was abstract um i didn't
want to do something that was just a
performance i didn't want to do
something that was
that was kind of inaccessible i wanted
to tell a story that was connected to
even if it's not the story of the song
that connected to the song
because what i do is is storytelling and
i wanted to people i wanted it to make
it feel more accessible not
not kind of just just have something to
look at while you're listening to it so
um it was a specific kind of video that
i'm kind of interested in
fans of shadow and bowen are highly
anticipating and anxiously awaiting the
second season of that show
where are you at in the production of
season two have you started filming any
of it yet or is that something happening
imminently soon
we haven't started and i don't know i
don't know exactly when we're going to
um but i'm i'm hopeful it will be soon
but um i'm i'm i'm i'm waiting as uh
with it with as much anticipation as as
those
um
as those fans you're talking about i'm
one of them um
but uh i'm excited to see what they do
with it and i'm excited to see when we
can when we can get going i know that uh
sean levy has said that all of the
scripts have been written have you read
them all do you want to read them all do
you not get that far ahead of yourself
i would quite happily gobble them up
today if they arrived on my doorstep but
no nothing's been shared with me yet um
uh
uh you know the uh the spies at netflix
are keeping them safe uh but uh uh i'm
excited yeah i don't just i just don't i
wish i wish i had secrets to spill
um
i just i find that interesting because
you know usually with the tv show you
don't get an entire season ahead of time
they're not
typically you know all the scripts
aren't written ahead of time so it seems
like it feels a little bit different
at least if that opportunity is there
yeah it's um
i always find it more you know more it
appeals to me to be able to look at the
arc of the of the season to be able to
like sort of balance things and judge
things and know how much to pull back
and how much to to give
um
uh
so i i prefer it that way but it was
also something exciting about working on
something like westworld for example
where you had no clue where it was going
so you just had to go kind of balls to
the wall and just just just just
don't leave anything in the tank because
you don't know what it is next week you
might be shot so um
obviously too with such a when you're
telling a story in such an expansive
world as shadow and bone there's a lot
of story to tell there's a lot of
characters to explore
have you had any conversations about how
many seasons the show could go do you
have any idea what they're thinking
about that
i i know i don't know i mean i know that
uh i know that eric archaron is very
keen to get to the six of crows uh
stories i love i know he loves a heist
and he loves those characters and he
read that first i know that much so he's
keen to get on with that um
uh
and uh yeah i'm excited to see how they
could how they could kind of um
sew it all up i'm not envious of that
task you know i think they did an
amazing job in the first season of
of having the stories kind of you know
pre sort of prequel to six crows into
link with the shadow and bone stories um
i i'm beyond curious to see how they do
it going forwards but i think so long as
i get to say the juiciest darkening
lines that i've written on my list i'll
be happy
it's it's such a fun show because
especially
i mean the first season was great but i
love where all the characters are left
because it just feels like there's so
much to dig into
yeah well almost every character has
kind of had the rug pulled out from
underneath them but is sort of looking
facing forwards knowing what they sort
of want to do now whereas i think uh
they all quite
yeah and i think i think that's
interesting uh
an interesting
moment to leave things out
when a project comes your way and you
know that it's a horror anthology series
from guillermo del toro do you even need
to know anymore before saying yes or did
you feel like
that was enough
no you don't need to know anything um
you just say i just said yes which i
never ever do and also i always said to
my team that i would know my mind and
manager and everything i've had for 20
years i will never do a horror and never
do a horror because i don't watch them
and i don't i don't like feeling creeped
out i don't mind being sort of like
thrilled i love psychological thrillers
and being sort of like scared but i
don't like feeling creeped out so um
it's not something that i actively seek
out
but if it's guillermo del toro you know
there's going to be kind of speaking of
two things at once you know he's going
to do something else with it as well you
know there's going to be
a humanity to it you know there's going
to be
you know something to it which is which
has something else to say for itself and
he's been very hands-on with
the the sort of creative process and
choosing all the stories and choosing
the cast and choosing designing some of
the some of the features of it so um
uh
you know i just i just sort of said yes
and and and it turned out to be a really
interesting character and they were very
collaborative and there were certain
themes that i wanted to sort of pull out
of this particular story that i was
doing which i can't say what it is yet
but it's um
uh
you know i i think it's something that's
something that i'll be really proud of
we do know that it is based on a short
story by hp lovecraft so how does that
influence like the tone and
that was the thing that was the thing i
was going to say that i didn't think i
could say but you do know well i mean
it's it's in the credits so i'm guessing
that's it i don't think it said what but
it said it's not a great story so how
does that influence the tone vibe of
everything like is there a very specific
tone and vibe when you're
in a world like that
um i i think it's quite uh it's i will
say that the the the the what we made is
very different from the short story it's
much more expanded than than this
particular short story is this story's
about one tiny element of what we've
made so it's kind of an original fresh
feeling thing
um
but with certainly the the sort of main
thread of the story is is taken from
this short story and the two main
characters but um
uh
you know it felt like we were making
something new and fresh even though it
was sort of like set over different um
time periods uh so uh
excited about it i'm just hesitant
because i'm not sure what i'm allowed to
say and what i'm not but um yeah no i
can't
how is the experience of working with
someone like chrisman glover because
he's also an actor that
is unpredictable
yeah totally unpredictable and that's
one of the great things about working
about you never know you know he likes
to try takes in different ways and
scenes in different ways and he loves
doing it and he's excited about the
characters he's he's crafting and it's
so fun to watch him do that and he likes
to sort of like talk about uh
like i do he likes to sort of download
what we're trying to do with any
particular scene and and
make each scene the kind of
most uh
full version of it of itself um
so so he's a great collaborator in that
way and and and i think it's important
in a genre like that to have people who
are gonna be a bit unpredictable um
um
but still have a sort of verve
for
for making it exciting and and he has
all those things
i just i love the work that guillermo
del toro does just because he he feels
like
a big kid in the sense of his
imagination and all of these creatures
and characters he comes up with and yet
he can still be very terrifying at the
same time and i just
kind of love that combination
yeah this story definitely has all of
all of those things it feels very uh
very uh
sort of period uh period game of detour
so it's good
he's he's definitely a character well i
i'm curious i mean since it took like
20 years or more to get to this point
with your music
are you thinking about putting out
more music or working on music anytime
soon is it something you always do like
are you always
playing around with that kind of thing
i mean i'm always sitting at the piano
and playing uh songs that i love and uh
trying to or trying to at least um and
just sort of enjoying doing it uh and
i'm always writing down lyrics and
phrases and little things um you know
often for people's birthdays or or if
they're feeling a bit down i'll write
them like a little
short little poem of some kind just just
because i think it's like
i like thoughtfulness and i like that
kind of um
i like that kind of communication which
is a bit more thoughtful and so i'm
always doing stuff with words the actual
sort of sitting down till i finish the
songs is something i need a bit more
space for
um
so tends not to happen if i'm working on
a show or something or
or a film but um
uh
i definitely want to i've caught the bug
i definitely want to do more and uh
whether that's
you know that whether that's involves
doing some more covers or some different
sort of genres or whatever then then
then that'd be great i'd love to perform
the songs at some point for people uh
i'd love to do some shows i don't know
how or when or what but um
i you know it's nice to be able to write
a list of ambitions you know
yeah i mean is it hard to even think
about doing live performances between
your acting projects and just in general
with covid how you even can like work
something i need more help in my life i
i need more i need more support in my
life i'm realizing um if i want to do
more than one thing but uh i hope maybe
i'll get that and maybe we can find a
way to do that
when you are
figuring out the writing process of
writing a song and working on getting
your thoughts out that way has it ever
made you think about writing a script or
writing in that sense i mean
does one even translate into the other
yeah i i would like i have written a
couple of scripts in in my life with
particularly with sort of with people i
would like to to
to it's the same as the songs though
i've not felt like any one of them is
confident enough to like really take
because the effort to get something from
a script onto a screen is inordinate and
the same with a song to get it from
something i can play over there just for
my own ears and something that is
available to like buy on a on a vinyl
whatever or a cd and like is a full
thing with a video and this that
i mean it was just it was the last year
and a bit year and a half
you know completely um to to do that
because you want it to be what you set
out for it to be and it would definitely
be the same with with a film or or a
show so um
yes i i continue to sort of dabble with
with writing um
scenes and scripts and stuff but it
there are moments where it's been felt
more important that something i wanted
to do maybe i want to direct maybe
whatever and then and then you're like
no but actually if i have time that is
outside of acting i want to be doing
music with it so
you know is it
you've only got sort of limited hours in
the day but
at some point yeah i would like to have
tried everything i would like to make
you know a film at some point that was
out of my head or or
myself with you know with a writing
partner or something yeah i do i love
that process i have so much experience
with
breaking down other people's scripts
that it stood me in very good stead but
um we'll have to see if it's any ever
something that kind of comes to fruition
is there an artist whose music that you
listen to but you would never want to
touch covering any of their songs
because you'd be afraid that it just
wouldn't work with how you sound
i i would have a go go a go of it but i
know there are artists that sort of
perform in genres that i don't um
you know i i just
i uh
i'm not afraid of it but because because
you're never gonna sort of you know you
can't
um
sing a stevie wonder song and sound like
stevie wonder you just you bet i've
heard some great covers of that stuff um
i think i i
life is too short to be envious of of
those kinds of people and their voices
and their soul and their
you know
phrase phrasing or whatever it might be
but i do sometimes listen to artists who
just like cut right through to
to the
the soul or the joy of something or the
pain or something and i'm ju and i get i
get sort of stuck in in time in a in a
moment and you think that that's the
kind of like something sacred i listen
to an irish artist called foy vance a
lot at the moment um who i just think is
kind of magical in that way um
[Music]
but yeah what happens to me all the time
listening to music
it's interesting especially too when i
hear artists take on somebody's song
that you would like never picture them
singing either
i'll never forget the first time i heard
uh the van travis seeing britney spears
hit me baby one more time in such a way
that yeah i've heard that i've heard
that it's a great cover i love it when
people do that
it makes the emotions so different
yeah well because you could really also
bring out the lyrics i think when you
write something sometimes it only comes
out with a one way because that's how
you meant it and i think but i think uh
people cover it they it's like the
experience of someone listening to it
they they kind of bring out the
the words or the chord or the or the
moment or the pause even that feels
what th that was the part of the song
that they related to so i i love i love
i love all kind of kinds of covers i
think i think i think
i think we should all be [ __ ] like i
said we should all be sharing it so
share
yeah it's so interesting share your toys
yeah it's so interesting when you hear a
song and it's a song that you really
love but it takes you a minute to
realize that's the song because of what
somebody did with the cover of it i
think that's always so interesting
absolutely yeah i i have
so many
so many of those uh that i kind of
listen to and there are bands who
exclusively do that
there are bands like the scary pockets
for example you do just like funk covers
with guessings of all sorts of things
all the time
and
they put out albums of it and it's great
well now that this album is done it's
coming out how do you feel most
creatively fulfilled by this experience
does it
i mean after 20 years of thinking about
it does it live up to what you hoped it
might be
listen it doesn't sound like i thought
it was going to sound i thought it would
sound more like the people that i love i
thought it would sound more ray charles
but like of course i'm not harry charles
so it sounds me it sounds more me
uh it's just that you don't necessarily
know what that is and um sort of
dropping those expectations of wanting
it to sound like anything else is it was
a big part of this for me um
and um
but but people lit close to me saying
it's that the music sounds like i am as
a person was a big part of it to seeing
like i said i think seeing people's
smiling faces kind of dance dancing to
something you made is an incredible
sort of bountiful experience
um
but just being able to like almost go on
spotify or other music and like click on
a song that's mine and it plays like
that still is like magical to me
and and and it will never be deleted
like it i mean it's there now
and
no matter
how old and doddery i get
you can still press play on it and that
that to me is like the very few things
in life that are that kind of um
tangible
well i appreciate you talking to me
about everything i i've always been so
interested in your career because like i
said at the beginning of this
the characters you play just have so
many levels going on with them i mean
especially
a character like the one you play in
shadow and bone is like the most perfect
example because there are so many layers
going on with that guy
well i i you know it's like that's how i
look at everything if i if i feel
something it is a bit one-dimensional i
want i want to dig until i find the
truth you know
until i find something that feels
more like the human experience which is
always a little bit more gray and always
a little bit more combative and always
has a bit more tension in it and always
has a bit more uh
uh
you know
we're all
we're all creatures who don't underst
you know who don't who can't understand
um one thing without the other if we
were never sad we wouldn't know what
happy felt like so so
let you know just sort of
reassuring each other that we
all all are built that way is is
something i'm interested in
well i appreciate you talking to me
about it all i will uh
definitely be tuning in to cabinet of
curiosities when it comes out
yeah that sounds like it might be up
your street i think it's going to be
very cool
yeah anything anything like that any i
just i love
the visual the imagery i love how all of
it comes together because it seems like
there's so many layers that have to work
with those kind of projects that it just
i love that especially when it's
like black mirroring
yeah yeah it's a little bit black mirror
in that they're all separate um so so
there may be some episodes you respond
to more than others which i think is
always kind of very exciting as well but
the same kind of team have put them
together so there's like a
there's like a flow to it
well i'm looking forward to that and
more shadow and bone and whatever else
you have coming up acting and music wise
so thank you
thank you so much
you